à chambord il faut attendre l'obscurité
pour que la lumière se fasse sur les 160
m de façade un spectacle à la grandeur
du monument et aux reflets historique
très beau et magnifique c'est très joli
très très beau
d'autant plus qu'on ne s'y attendait pas
quelques chanceux au soir de la générale
et toute une équipe en coulisses
l'installation dé lui zone de projection
est à réaliser uniquement de nuit une
semaine de travail de représentation
la production se doit d'être à la
hauteur
c'est une machine qui permet de faire
des faisceaux très puissant ça va
permettre ce soir de détendre un petit
peu le site vers le ciel un son et
lumière tout feu tout flamme et avant le
feu d'artifice final une trentaine
d'artistes spécialisés en pyrotechnie on
va principalement manipuler des flammes
pur ça va être un des effets avec cette
ombre elle qui va s'enflammer pour
l'accompagner résidente de chambord ces
deux soirées sont aussi un défi
technique avec la vingtaine de chevaux
puisque l'artifice feu charbon mapping
donc là nous c'était un pari assez
assez culotté de mettre les chevaux dans
un tel environnement environnement
particulier cette année les travaux de
restauration de la façade battent leur
plein
faire de cette contrainte un avantage
c'est tout l'intention du metteur en
scène au lieu d'essayer d'oublier ses
échafaudages je me suis dit ok on va
l'utiliser pasquet on a utilisé comme
titre le mot renaissance qui est lié
évidemment à l'histoire mais avec des
échafaudages tu as aussi la renaissance
du château
une pleine renaissance pour le château
car c'est aussi le premier événement
post-pandémie prêt à accueillir autant
de public dix mille personnes par soir
[Musique]